i'm an engineer i make six figures by
myself so i'm pretty well established on
my own what are you stuck on so what's
not working for you well i keep uh like
all these single moms they keep coming
after me and it's like is that all i can
get dude it's simple like the older you
get the more women that you're gonna
come across that have kids in tow from
prior relationships some are gonna have
several from several different guys
and they're really just looking for
captain save a whole they've already had
their fun the thing that you got to be
really careful with now is that you
don't do something stupid like an invite
a woman in your life that's got like
three kids from three different fathers
because you want to play captain save a
whole that's what you got to be really
careful with all you have to do do is
just understand okay like what else can
you do to improve life you have to make
sure that you're engaging that you're
captivating and that you've got
interesting things to invite gorgeous
women in to come and do with you right i
don't understand my beta but can a a guy
like me become an alpha to like dude
you're gonna come over the [ __ ] you want
you